5 grand a month you might seem like a
lot but you make that now from just
selling a deal and how many deals do you
sell a week last week we did 18 Grand in
Deal selling
18,000 there's been times where I've
spent my last1 just coming down to the
meal you say it's going to be 4 and then
it's actually 308 they're going to be
like well that was my finders for paid
for now they're going to be your biggest
fan now they're going to Rave about you
now they're going to pass you referrals
brought my first property I spent my
last 10 grand just on the deposit and I
had nothing in the end I made 40 Grand
profit from it the best way to make good
friends with agents is to buy from them
I spend probably 6 hours a week on the
phone to new Academy members just asking
for advice on how to do things how easy
do you think it is for the average
person brand spanking now to be able to
just go into deal sign and sell a dealer
mon Nathan good to see you bro
congratulations on going fulltime in
property bro thank you what have been
your main strategies and what what do we
want to talk about today what what value
should we give folks today so I started
out in property uh before I joined the
academy i' i' flipped a house I lived in
it at the same time made about 40 Grand
profit doing respect boom 40 Grand from
one flip yeah yeah nice and then joined
the academy got a rent to rent with a JV
partner then took another one on um and
now I've got three with uh different JV
Partners good up and down uh are you
full-time n proor yes what did you do
before I Was A L driver by how was that
I didn't didn't really like it too much
you're not treated very nicely in the
industry to be honest you you're treated
like crap the other drivers no by uh by
management okay yeah yeah so were you
paid well though yeah I was paid well I
was self-employed so I had my own
limited company and I was I was doing
like contractor work for for Co-Op and
and other places like that I don't
understand why people do a job that they
don't enjoy it paid well it paid well
how much were you paid I was earning
roughly between 800 to 12200 a week but
I was working very long hours for that
but even that though you might seem like
a lot like a grand a week for four grand
five grand a month but you make that now
from selling a deal yeah yeah exactly
and how many deals do you sell a week I
mean a month a month well last week we
we did 18 Grand in Deal selling just
last week
18,000 yeah yeah damn so that's
incredible how does it feel to be making
that kind of money in a week it's
lifechanging and it's it's it's little
things like uh I've not spent a lot of
money really I've brought my m a Range
Rover so she likes that and uh she got a
wardrobe com in a triple wardrobe big
fancy wardrobe so she's married we're
not we're not actually married yet I
call her my wife but we're not because
she's wife IM material you will marry
her I will mate and what what's the name
of your company bet Estates limited yeah
what does that mean it's my kids's Nam
so Brooklyn Elsie and Teddy wow well I
want to really have a valuable interview
right now I want to delve into what
you've done learn the skills and just
pass as much as we can for people cuz my
listeners my subscribers are you you
were one of my subscribers at one point
hopefully you yeah I was going to say
but like you know what I mean like
they're good people so deal selling I
mean I know you got rent to rents I know
you've done your house flip I made 40
Grand on that but deal selling is the
thing that you probably make most of
your money from yeah right now yes yeah
yeah so how do you sell a deal how do
you even begin to start how does it work
what's the business look like so
starting off when when you're first
starting off the key is just to network
with everybody get as many contacts as
you can and stuff like that and
reputation a big thing as well being
known as a nice guy I spend probably 6
hours a week on on the phone to new
Academy members just asking for advice
on how to do things so I I'll break it
down for them and I'll say just just
make sure you're showing up to
everything the Monday night masterminds
the academy meals for a long time I I
wasn't showing up and it's only since
I've started showing up and coming to
the the dinners and going to the
masterminds and stuff like that that
it's really started to take off and
posting myself a lot more on social
media as yeah that's good man just
getting yourself out there helping
people creating Good Karma and I can
testify that that's something that you
do do especially within the within the
academy and also when you're dealing
with other Academy members you're
talking to people that have they're not
leeches I had one guy messaged me
yesterday and he said Samuel can you
move to my house for a week and do a
Financial Freedom challenge with me I
said have you been to a crash course he
said I know it's a bit too
far I'm like bro there's been times
where I've spent my last1 just coming
down to the meal yeah I've I've put it
in fuel and just come down yeah to the
network and stuff last1 pound what about
the academy like when you joined was
that a massive sacrifice joining the
academy it was yeah it was how you how
did you get them was it savings loan
it's from the house sale okay flipped
the house made 40 Grand and put put 12
into the academy yeah yeah but you know
people that are saying to me can you
come and spend a week at my house but
they won't travel an hour and a half
yeah yeah to come to a
one program where I'm going to be there
for a full day pouring my heart out
teach for a full day and you're like I
can't bother to come to that but can you
come to me yeah the disrespect man it's
just nuts isn't it yeah it is it is okay
so that's the first thing so getting
yourself networked getting yourself in
the right Community giving value
building your reputation within a
community then what then it's a case of
finding good deals because there's a lot
of deal sellers out there that will try
and sell things that are if it's a rent
to rent for example they're saying it's
breaking even at 60% I've turned people
away when they the' asked me to source
and I'm like it's not a good deal you
need to work on your numbers a bit more
and make sure your numbers are correct
yeah and it's the after care as well for
example we had one where we we'd signed
the contracts with the agents and then
the agents had fell out with the uh the
landlord or or what whatever happened
and the landlord had decided to rent it
to somebody else but my investor had
already spent 2,300 on on maintaining
the place and getting it nice ready for
guests coming in Nightmare y so what do
you you spoke selling as well uh not at
the minute no okay so if I came to you
and said I want a brr in Derby I'd find
it for you yeah you'd find it can you
basically find anything in Derby yeah
especially with brrs I know the market
very well yeah I've got a lot of
contacts with agents in that area so and
and the best thing about Derby is
there's no Article 4 right now so
there's there's a few streets that have
got it in and stuff like that they're
trying to get it in I've seen I've seen
the protesters why is that a good thing
to anyone listening why is it a good
thing that there's no article for and
what does that even mean so it's it's a
good thing because you buy property
you'll renovate it turn it into a uh a
HMO and uh there's no you won't need a
license for it unless it's less than how
many beds was five or more bed so but
the good thing is when article four does
come in it's going to increase the value
of the house sure because that now
everyone else needs planning permission
okay so you will go out and find deals
whether that be brrs rent to rents buy
tillet whatever it is that investors are
looking for and then how will you then
go from finding a deal
to then selling it and getting money
from an investor so it's all market
research as well so um negotiating the
purchase price um quoting the referb you
get contacts to my Builders my power
team and stuff if you're buying
something in Derby I'll either offer
project management as well so they'll be
able to have a completely hands-off
experience um and and know that it's
just looked after by me I'll work out
what the gdv is and everything and just
present the figures as they are but
sometimes I'll I'll over inflate the
figures maybe I I'll say the the referb
is maybe going to cost 30 grand oh J M I
thought for a minute you meant over
inflate the gdv that wouldn't be very
smart so when you say you mean be super
conservative about things like the
refurb cost yeah yeah why do you do that
what if the referb is going to be 40 why
would you say it's going to be 50 under
promise and overd deliver I guess bang
yeah yeah and that prevents refunds yep
yeah 100% because if you say the refund
is going to be 48 and it's actually
going to be 42 the Investor's going to
go out and go well you said 40 now it's
4 whereas if you do it the other way
around you say it's going to be 40 and
then it's actually 30 or 35 they're
going to be like well that was my
finders fee paid for now they're going
to be your biggest fan now they're going
to Rave about you now they're going to
pass you referrals so how many deals are
you sell on average like a month how
much you how many did you sell last
month um off the top of my head I don't
even know do you know what you turn it
over roughly with your deal selling
business I mean last week you said you
did
18 incredible good week um but I'd say
average probably anywhere between 8 to
12 Grand something like that per per
month 8 to 12 Grand profit yeah yeah but
last week I was just I didn't stop I was
constantly so you're making about double
triple what you were making as a lorry
driver but last week was particularly
awesome yeah um why was last week so
good I think I just hyperfocused on Deal
selling last week and I put all my time
and energy into into just deal selling
just to see how much I could get done
yeah so what what's the biggest asset to
being a deal seller is it about having
great deals is it about having access to
the investors is it the skills the
ability to be to get the sale what you
say is the biggest strength I'm a I'm a
people person anyway when I left school
I worked in a chip shop for about six
years so it's customer service based
right so I like I like helping people
out as well and building that reputation
I guess being known in the community
yeah yeah how did you justify in Rolling
onto the academy and how has that been
so I came to a pound Crush course when I
was in the middle of doing my referb I
didn't sign up for any Advanced Training
then because every penny that I needed
kind of had to be spent on the refurb of
the house but uh I carried on watching
your YouTube videos I carried on uh I
signed up to the 365 MH uh I can't
remember it was minimal amount I was
speaking to Elliot a lot and uh Elliot
went into great detail into what the
academy is and stuff like that so as
soon as I had the money I um I rang
Elliot and I said uh are you've got a
discovery day I'm going to come down to
that and he put me on that and then uh
and then whilst I was down there
obviously learning a bit more about the
academy and stuff like that and then
enrolled a couple of days later I think
and when was that uh actually so I'm now
on my second year of the nice you're an
associate member now so how's it been
was it what you expected more than yeah
more than yeah I I told my partner um
when I'd left the barn that um that I'd
enrolled and I hadn't but I wanted to
see what her reaction had I wanted to
see what her reaction would be uh and it
wasn't a it wasn't a positive one but it
was more like the fact that i' spent
that money and not not spoken to her
about it beforehand but when I got home
she she just she was encouraging she
yeah yeah she just said if you think you
can make this work then go for it what
does she think about how much money
you're bringing in there well she she
loves it and and the fact that I'm home
more did b a Range Rover yeah well can't
really argue with that Kenya of course
she's happy yeah yeah okay so you got
your investor list you got your deals
cool how do you sell these deals what
are you saying to the investors to the
investors again a lot of it now somebody
will message me about it and then they
they'll want to pay straight away and
I've not even got them on the phone
because I think the reputation's there
but I always do try and get them on the
phone and say look this is the deal
these are the figures if there's
anything that you're not happy with then
you've got the 14-day calling off period
in our seas and C's that you're going to
sign um and and just talk through
everything with them and I'll say there
there's Aftercare there as well not just
going to sell you a deal and then say
see you later a lot of people uh for
Brent R for example it's going to be
their first deal that they're buying and
and they want to know what channel
manager to use or or how to systemize
things a bit better um so I'll go over
that with them as well and I'll are you
a natural salesman no are you an
extrovert or an introvert extrovert
probably probably an extrovert but not a
natural sales person um what's SK what
are the strongest sales skills that
you've learned from doing what you're
doing that you'd pass on to other people
listening just customer service based
and care for your customers like I said
that deal that my investor went wrong we
we actually sorted her out with another
deal and I discounted her the money that
she'd spent on yeah on the last deal
that she'd lost so I'm losing money but
it's because I care about my customers
and I want them to man well that I'm
really glad to hear it because when you
know how to sell because you do know how
to sell people might be watching
thinking does he know how to sell
talking a lot about customer being
customer based and care about the
customer which is really important that
will keep your reputation but being able
to sell is a skill in itself yeah and I
know a lot of people a lot of nice guys
who really care about their customers
they really care about their businesses
but they can't sell and guess what
they're broke you have to be able to
sell so give me a role play so I'll be
I'll be an investor yeah right let's say
you got BR in Derby and I'm an investor
Nathan it looks really good just give me
a few days to think about it well what
is stopping you right now what what do
you need to the thing that's holding me
back is just I gu just want to process
everything it's a big decision Nathan
you know it is you're buying a house
it's one of the biggest things to ever
do and you've just bought it to me five
minutes ago kind of makes sense but I I
just feel like I just need to sleep on
it process it for a few days yeah yeah
of course of course you need to do it
and it's a br it's a big projects right
so you're going to need to take time to
process it and stuff but this is what
you have your 14-day calling off period
for because you need to do all your due
diligence I'm going to be here to Hold
Your Hand the whole process anyway
you're going to get access to my power
team Builders whatever if you want me to
project manage it I'll project manage it
for you as well is there anything else
that's that's bothering you
um it's not really that's bothering me
um so I've got a 14-day calling period
yeah so if if in those 14 days I go out
and I look at it and I'm not really too
sure and I want a refund I can get a
refund within the 14 days from the
finders fee yep yep 100% and what's your
finders fee it's 3,000 all right well
would it be I mean I just feel like I at
least need to speak to my wife you know
and just see how she feels about the
situation yeah of course she do of
course she do what do you think she'd
say my wife what do you think she'll say
I think I guess if we've got a calling
off period of 14 days and you know I
think I think she'll probably be up frit
really okay so what we do right now then
is is take the payment um and then and
then you've got these 14 days to go and
speak to your wife go and do all your
duty diligence um and and then come back
to me and let me know what you think how
would you like to pay I mean maybe bank
I could do maybe a bank transfer yeah
bank transfer is fine do you want to do
that now while on the phone yeah all
right no worries okay watch your details
there we go Nathan knows how to sell
boom so what happened just dealing with
objections and this is all the stuff
that you learn on the academy anyway how
to deal with various different
objections because I think is you're
going to get that aren't you yeah yeah
yeah and I get it as well from an
Investor's point of view I get why they
they probably don't know me um or or
they've never heard of me before and I'm
I'm asking them for £3,000 it's a lot of
money to some people so but this is the
great thing right because you've been
conservative with the numbers now
they've paid 3,000 now they're going to
be thinking no one's going to pay 3,000
for a laugh if they've paid £3,000 up
front they're serious about the deal but
they may ask for a refund if the deal is
not everything that you promised if it's
everything and more why are they going
to ask for a refund 100% 100% they're
very unlikely to yeah so that's a good
bit of sales there why did you why did
you say to me um when I said about I
need to speak to my wife and you said
what do you think you wife will say why
did you say that because they know
they're just trying to store so so they
know why what what the wife's going to
say they just want a bit more time to
think about it but that's again that's
what the 14-day calling off per is and
also let's be real the property game
it's fast yeah it's fast yeah so if a
deal comes along you can't be saying oh
all right you have a few days and you
it's not going to be around in a few
days if you've put an offer on a
property the offer has been accepted the
agent wants your photo ID sists details
moring principal proof of funds
correspond address and they want it now
and before we even get into the
nitty-gritty I ask these sort of
questions these qualifying questions
right talk to me about that then let's
role play again but let's assume that
this is the beginning of the call so you
just sent me out an email and you just
said I got this BR these are the figures
brilliant deal it's in Derby yeah if you
want to reserve it text me and let's
have a conversation I've just seen that
email I've just text you okay this is
that conversation so the first thing
I'll do is obviously ring you up hello
Samuel speaking hi Samuel you've dropped
me a message about a
br that you're interested in did I was
interested in it actually yeah okay J uh
just ask you a few questions and go
through it all yeah yeah absolutely fine
so the first thing obviously this this
property's uh £80,000 purchase it's got
25 grand um referb that's that's that's
needed on it what sort of funds are you
working with is this something that you
can afford or uh yeah um I've got a I've
got a broker who's got me a bridging a
bridging loan for the refurb and the
actual purchase 80 grand I've got that
in savings okay perfect and what's your
experience in BR this will be my first
one but I have got two boletes okay do
you need access to a power team um I
mean listen I wouldn't mind having yeah
maybe a chat with you about if you've
got Builders and stuff absolutely yeah
100% so we've got Builders that's
actually quoted on the referb on this so
we've got solid quotes in um we can we
can give you access to them if you want
um yeah so what interested you in this
property um it was really just the fact
that I'm I'm tired of saving up money
and putting it into a b toet and renting
it out I want something where I can buy
some it refurb it and then I can refin
pull my money back out and recycle the
80 grand that I've got cuz I think my 80
grand that I got now rather than sinking
it into a property I want to put it into
a property pull my money back out and
keep doing that again and again and grow
my part and I thought that this property
could be potentially suitable for a for
a pull your money out yeah 100% And and
you are going to be able to pull all
your money out on this one is there
anything that you would like to know
about this property in order to make an
informed decision I think I've got
everything I just want to see it I just
want to go out have a look at it you
know see the builders quotes obviously I
need to to you know speak speak to my
wife um get my advisor to just look at
it and whatnot but I'm you know assuming
that I've seen it and it's good I'm
pretty much ready to go okay so what
we're going to do at this stage then is
we'll send you over some seas and sees
that need sign in there's a 3,000
finders fee for this deal you have
14-day calling off period this this is
for you to do your end due diligence
make sure you're happy with the deal and
everything else how would you like to
pay closed man now I hit you with the
objections and you just l round that's
cool so what you did there was so clever
is is you made me have to qualify myself
y cuz most investors will ring you up
and they'll say tell me about the deal
what's this what's this what's this but
you said h on can I ask you some
questions how you going to be financing
it what was it to CAU your
eye every time I always qualify an
investor because if it's a rent to rent
deal for example maybe it's only £10,000
that need to spend but it it might only
have eight yeah yeah sometimes or they
might not pass the preferen here yeah or
they might think that they're buying a
passive income stream and understand
that they're buying a business
opportunity cuz we've sold deals with
referencing sometimes they need 85 Grand
plus salary and stuff like that have to
qualify them yeah yeah yeah and that's
another thing that will stop the refund
happening MH so do you love deal selling
I do yeah I do it's very active you're
very good at it bro you think you m 18
Grand last week you're very good at it
you're a good sales person but the good
thing about you is you're so customer
focused it's a
responsibility and also having the
skills I'm not being funny but I am a
genius sales person right and I've
trained you how to sell sure so it
doesn't surprise me that you're good but
having the skills to be able to sell is
a power it's a superow MH and a
superpower comes with responsibility and
that responsibility is looking after
your customers you got and you know
first hand how we treat our students y
yeah I we do keep their asses sometimes
and I've kicked your ass a few times
yeah yeah especially the ACP talk to me
about that so I think I got the grilling
the most out of everybody out of
everybody there you got your ass kicked
yeah what happened I think you just said
I I was giving too much away not not
taking too much for myself really and
and and probably being too much of a
nice guy and that's right you were you
were you were doing a lot of codal
sourcing MH and you were you were
partnering with people and you were
doing percentage splits and all kinds of
stuff and joint ventures and you just
giving away too much I say on a minute
you're on the academy you've got the
invested list you've got the ability to
sell you're F what are you doing giving
people such high percentages yeah has
that helped a little bit sense it has
yeah and like I said since the acpp I I
never done an H Grand week but since the
acpp just like it's springboarded me
onto and I'm doing a lot of uh
management now so if if I'm selling rent
to rent deals and they want completely
hands off we're doing management for
them as well so it's nice when Academy
members get to come for two days at my
house and just receive inter mup
coaching and I was learning things off
other people on their struggles as well
and I okay yeah how easy do you think it
is from for the average person brand
spanking new nothing to be able to just
go into deal selling and sell a deal a
month it's not that hard really it's not
is it it's not it's not if you put the
time and the effort in like I said just
make make sure you come into to all the
events and and showing up and also a
deal a week the average deal might be
three four grand yeah that's ples the
average salary so now people say to me I
don't love my job I say how much you
earning if you say I don't have my job
and I'm earn 25 Grand a week then I
think okay but if you say I don't have
my job and I'm earning 25 Grand a year
I'm like well is what are you doing yeah
just leave do deal selling how did you
find the crash course it was good I
spent the whole day I think I was the
last to leave and I talk some numbers
from there as well and I still still
speak to one person that I met there so
wow yeah yeah how's life changed then in
the last year or two since you've become
full-time in property I've got a lot
more time at home with the kids and and
the MS yeah and the wife to be is that
one of the most important reasons for
you it is yeah many in my family have
not really done very well uh my granddad
passed away at 51 and on New Year's Eve
on my bathroom floor my dad passed away
a couple of years ago he was only 45 so
for me I I've always always had that
subconscious thing in my head that maybe
I'm going to die young you're going to
live long you're going to live long bro
but I want to leave something behind for
the kids like you see I'm I'm from a
counselor State I my mom did her best
growing up she she always gave us
everything that she could but it it was
rough it's not a nice place I don't want
that for my kids I want them to not have
the struggles that I had necessarily but
also not be spoiled at the same time
what was the biggest drive then for you
getting into property in the first place
what was the real thing that was making
you think I have to do this I've always
liked property even when I was younger I
used to watch homes under the hammer
with my mom and stuff like that so I'd
always liked the idea of doing property
so when I brought my first property I
spent my last 10 grand just on the
deposit and I had nothing to do the
referb with and I just yeah I just
worked like a dog for two years it took
me two years to do but in the end I made
40 Grand profit from it so it was
definitely worth it and then it's
springboarded me on to joining the
academy and then yeah and then going on
from there what's been the hardest
aspect of transitioning from a lorry
driver to a property Tycoon I don't
think there is a a real Challenge from
from doing it's just been great yeah
yeah obviously hard work at times and I
know you hardships deal very active and
you have and you have things falling
through and you've got to keep everybody
happy you what you can't do as a deal
seller is you can't put your head under
the sand and just say oh la la la la if
there's issues if there's a estate
agents that are not happy or if there's
deals that are falling through or if
investors you got to be a man pick up
the phone and deal with it sure and
that's hard and that's what I was saying
when my investor had spent 2,300 on on
that property that and the deal had fell
through for for whatever reason between
the landord and the agent for for two
days I was in my own head I messaged you
as well and I was man I feel I'm bed but
I remember what I said do you remember
what I said to you yeah yeah I do yeah
yeah you said the facts that um I'm
bummed out and I care about my customers
and stuff like that is a good thing yeah
um it shows me that you care and uh
things things will work out in the end
and I also said one one time to you
don't worry about what's in your head
worry about what's in your bank there we
go do you remember that one yeah yeah
cuz sometimes it can you be oh man my
head's all over the place or it's
stressful or you know don't worry about
what's in your head wor about what's in
your bank because that's how you keep
track of the score yeah if bank's big
100% I think for a long time I wasn't
coming to the meals and stuff like that
and I got a Bolling off Kieran Connelly
as well yeah on the academy and uh yeah
cuz you got to you got to get around
yeah yeah cuz I'm buying a house now and
I've got um I'm using bridg in and then
I've got an investor that's giving me
30,000 for for the extras as well how
much are you putting in yourself
probably about 10 to 15 for the refer
beautiful yeah so you're basically
putting in no money yeah how much you
buying the house for uh 85 refurb 15 end
value 140 150 how did you find it for an
agent for an agent yeah i' brought from
these previously I brought from the
thing man the best way to make good
friends with agents is to buy from them
M and it's partner negotiating the price
as well so originally it was on the
market for 130 and then the deal had
fell down to 85 yeah yeah they put it
down to 110 because it the buyer had
pulled out for whatever reason I think
it was UN mortgageable and they couldn't
get a mortgage right when I listed my
offer I put in
83427 like a really specific number so
it looked like i' done my sums and they
came back to me and say uh we really
need about 87 and I said no 87's not
good for me I'll meet you in the middle
and we'll just call it 85 if you want
and they accept that's a banger I need
to come to see that house yeah when are
you completing hopefully soon very soon
are you about to exchange contracts not
yet I need to bring my solist today
chase them up are you happier now what
you saying now you're in property
definitely yeah and I think it's little
things as well like when when we were
staging the property in London um I took
the the kids were off school school
holidays so I took the misses and the
kids down and start in a nice house and
we went to Pizza Hut in the evening and
I just like yeah order whatever you want
and it was like for the first time I
just sat and realized I'm not worrying
about what I've got in my bank it's just
it's nice to just relax and just m
deserved bro well done man you know what
it's been a real pleasure you're a
proper nice guy deserve the success and
I appreciate that you help out the new
Academy members spend time it I love
doing it yeah and I appreciate that what
would you says your final words of
advice to people listening to this right
now that want to get into deal sourcing
and then be like what you've done
showing up is is a massive thing there's
an old saying how big would you dream if
you knew you couldn't
fail and is it is it going to be one or
is it going to be today so just showing
up coming to the one pound course
finding out what it's all about and then
I love that man show up you heard it
here first if you want to get started in
property I'd love to spend a full day
with you at the property investors crash
course everything I know about property
condensed into one day's training I'm
going to be in Birmingham London
Manchester up and down the country if
you want to get your tickets they're
just one and I'll leave a link in the
description see you there God
bless
[Music]